so one of the main goals in an airport
terminal is simply here is the aircraft
and here are cars and buses and perhaps
even trains so how do we shorten that
distance take that aircraft and
basically move it through position right
there hi I'm Peter Ichiro and I'm the
design principle for the redesign of
LaGuardia airports terminal Bay
I was privileged to work on the design
or lead the design of all of these
projects today we're going to talk about
optimizing the design in an airport
terminal so there are three types of
Airport configurations linear in which
we have the land side and then the air
side the planes did not touch the
terminal they were parked not too far
remotely but they're parked outside of
the building just like the cars were
parked outside the building the linear
model that we see here it's very
efficient for a particular size of
airport generally regional airports as
you can see this one six gate looks like
they'd probably be planes for about
maybe a 200 passenger aircraft so for
this size Airport it's highly efficient
so then the airport evolved in the
industry started to expand so the plane
having a direct relationship to the main
terminal which was referred to as the
head house and that's a term borrowed
from trains it started with the idea of
taking that same linear building and
then modifying the air side component to
grow fingers where the planes are
located if you think of your hand as the
main terminal a linear then it grew
fingers to accommodate growth in the
airline industry so that would be finger
concept so this is a style of the old
LaGuardia in 1964 when this terminal
open it was a state-of-the-art facility
it really represented not only where we
are in air travel but where everyone
anticipated us going and a few things
happen that impacted that the first
thing was security security was
introduced into the terminals which
created a line right there the other
thing is that there's lots of aircraft
it's an airport and all those Airport
were about this big they held about a
hundred 150 people they were called 707s
and DC nines and this was the
terminology that anyone traveling at the
time kind of knew suddenly that size
aircraft in a span of about less than a
decade was replaced by that and suddenly
instead of providing that much space for
the 707 you needed that much space or
even that much space so you can see the
impact that by the introduction of this
one single aircraft which quadrupled the
capacity of a plane had a terminal
design as airports continue to grow the
design professionals started to
investigate the idea of a satellite
terminal which could be connected to the
head House check-in and departures and
amenities the security the planes and
the gate lounges are all located
conveniently away from the head house
and a satellite facility which is
connected either a piece of architecture
which can also operate as a finger or
that same connection could be a bridge
or a tunnel what we have in front of us
is a example of a satellite terminal
this is Charles DeGaulle
you actually entered the terminal went
into it to go through the the check-in
activities and security and then you
change direction you can see these
little bridges which become tunnels and
lead to these individual islands these
remote satellites this is our design for
the new LaGuardia at Terminal B you can
see from the image it utilizes the
satellite model with two satellites one
on the east and one on the west we
obviously had to design a new building
as a replacement to the existing the
constraint was that the existing had to
remain in operation for the sake of
clarity in this image the existing
terminal is here and it's roads coming
from the Grand Central kind of Swing
around like that
and then there were a series of fingers
which come out of the existing head
house the head house and finger
configuration has inefficiencies
inherent in its design and that occurs
really right in these locations wherever
there's an inside corner on
building you can't put an airplane in
the corner because it's just as an it's
an inefficient location the other thing
in terms of aircraft operations is when
an aircraft leaves a gate and turns on
its engines that thrust the blasts
coming out of the back of the jet engine
basically will knock over anything or
break anything damage anything within
about two or three hundred feet behind
the plane it basically cannot start its
engines into a point about right here it
takes a long time or a longer amount of
time to get that plane off the gate and
operational and on its way to a runway
so an operational benefit of the
satellite configuration and the
satellites which are connected via the
bridges is that a plane can actually
because you can park anywhere along the
perimeter can actually be backed out of
a gate and then immediately have a
quicker route to the runway and then to
depart so in either case the aircraft
has many options of going this way to
the runways or under the bridges and the
bridges enable a new route that
previously doesn't exist at LaGuardia
therefore we believe will contribute to
quicker taxi times from the gate to the
runway in the existing building there
are multiple decision points so there's
an opportunity to get lost that can
occur at four points and for decision
points where have the opportunity to
make the wrong decision so in designing
the new terminal we went from four
decision points of the existing building
to one decision point in the new
terminal now I'm going to compare the
important areas of the old LaGuardia and
the new LaGuardia when you're traveling
your frustration is probably
attributable to long lines and
inadequate spaces the existing check-in
counters the existing departures fall
utilizes a series of check-in counters
which let's call the old style which is
this linear arrangement that you
actually walk up to and interact with an
airline employee and check your bag as
you can see from this photograph behind
the airline employees is a wall you
really cannot see where you're going so
it's already a mystery if you will in
terms of where the next step is in the
process so what
introducing here at Terminal B really
has become the standard in the industry
the island it's referred to as the
island check-in just literally cost a
check in a series of kiosk which are
really kind of as you can see almost
Islands in this large space this image
for example at LaGuardia takes place
right there and the check-in counters
are here and the distance between the
check-in counters in the front door is
very limited so typically as soon as you
walk in because the ticket counters have
a queue and then people are trying to
walk in between the queues there's a
sense of congestion and things are
backing up you might check in here and
then because you're you're closer to
this one you might walk there and
realize you're on the wrong line and
then you might be able to understand
that I can walk along this path to get
to where I'm supposed to go or you might
reverse yourself and come back because I
know where I've already been in the
design of the new terminal we really
look to this idea of introducing a sense
of transparency introducing where you're
able to see your next step in the
process and those check-in positions as
you can see are not perpendicular to
walking into the building they're
parallel to it we're able to use almost
90% of the side of the island to check
passengers in the other benefit of this
arrangement is many passengers today
don't check luggage they already have a
boarding pass or their youth there it's
a short trip so they go right from the
front door through this space to
security we made a very conscious
decision and the design of this working
with our client to try and minimize the
dependency on signage to allow the
design of the terminal to create this
idea that itself navigates so assigns a
role about the hierarchy of information
in this environment which is pretty
neutral architectural II and pretty
neutral in terms of its palette the sign
really stands out and here the
architecture as you can see in this
image because the nature of it really
pulls you forward and what it's really
pointing towards it's pulling you
towards a spot of light so you're
naturally drawn to the light looking at
this image my eye is immediately drawn
to the people themselves and this is an
argument
people contribute a lot to the color of
an airport to the visual activity and
also it's hard to say it's like okay
gate lounge is a one through eight
where are they are they all right there
or are they to the left or to the right
the hierarchy the information is on this
image is not clear now let's move on to
security security at airports is a
necessity it is something that we as a
traveling public have to endure if
there's one area that contributes to
people's frustration at airports its
security so in the existing LaGuardia
Terminal Bay security was was located
and basically retrofitted into four
locations where the head housed the main
terminal meets the fingers security is
now really because of the demands the
requirements it demands its own space
and that space comes with its own
requirements spatially as we move
through security today we're actually
arriving at it through a generous portal
which is hosted 150 feet open so
everyone entering security goes through
this portal we created this large space
here which allows for tremendous amount
of flexibility in the design of the new
terminal what this really means is today
we have 12 in the future we'll have 22
when I come through security today I'm
confronted with this long narrow finger
full of congestion when I come through
security when the new terminal opens
there is a generous area that allows me
to put my watch back on to you know put
my jacket back on tie my shoes to put my
suitcase back together and then as soon
as you come through security there's
this wonderful window like a window out
onto the airfield while you're putting
our shoes back on or trying to think
where the next step is I already can see
the concourses I can see the planes and
I can see the bridges overhead the true
benefit of seeing the the tarmac of
seeing the apron and where the planes
are located and the concourse is you're
already able to see your destination it
puts your mind at ease
it eliminates the anxiety of the unknown
helps you gauge a distance I can see
that my plane is five gates away because
I can already see that
on b38 and I see that big sign that says
be 38 on the side of the building so if
we compare the existing concourse as
their fingers at LaGuardia today to what
is being built and what has been
designed for the future the first
noticeable difference is in the
dimension the existing concourse today
has circulation down the middle and then
gate lounges on either side of it this
entire dimension is 65 feet and it's
pretty much split into thirds so the
middle circulation is I think about 22
feet wide between the columns that
really define that space and then the
balances is split about you know 30 plus
feet on either side the proposed
concourse is 120 feet and the columns
are spaced a hundred feet apart with
size comes tremendous amount of
flexibility here there's the possibility
of spending time we have more
flexibility of how you use your time at
the airport it contributes to this this
idea of being in the Civic Room at the
airport as opposed to the processing
room at the airport the the long linear
hallway if we want to provide seating
for let's say a hundred even at 125
people we probably required that much
space what's available today at
LaGuardia is about that much space so
you can start to see really the
difference between a space which is
almost 25 feet wide and about 9 or 10
feet tall
versus the replacement concourse for the
terminal B concourse D the East
concourse already constructed the 120
feet between columns the ability to
allow the circulation to kind of
navigate less linear but just as direct
this is the D concourse you can see the
narrowness fit defined by the columns
and where there's no gate lounges that
space has been in filled with amenities
and and food and beverage but just
imagine as there's a line waiting to get
food here that line is already queuing
up into the circulation space and this
whole room is under sized so people are
actually already kind of queuing and
waiting for that plane to take off or to
board that plane in this space you can
see how already in
it's very inadequate space it becomes
even further constrained by its uses and
its ability to satisfy those uses we see
in this image this this paving in the
terrazzo floor was not original it was
probably from a generation or two ago
but the idea here was to create a visual
counterpoint to the long linear nature
of this and to start to break it down
into more perceptible modules of scale
we do the same thing with taking that
little hexagonal pattern and start to
create areas this modulation of the
floor to help delineate your travel and
to take what is essentially a large
pavilion like structure and then to
populate it with things that introduce
scale and a much more human quality to
it when you're standing in an airport
you you want to see as much as possible
you want to know where the stores are
where the retail is where my plane is or
where the gates are so at least I know
I'm walking in the right direction
restrooms other amenities airports today
are offering a lot more than food and
beverage as an amenity we want to pay a
lot of attention to arriving in New York
for that arriving passenger they begin
that journey as soon as they get off a
plane in the concourse and then the
escalate or take an elevator up to the
level of the bridge so they immediately
arrive in this wonderful kind of
monumental Civic space and then as soon
as they're on the bridge they're in a
rather unique environment
[Music]
one of the aspects of terminals of an
earlier generation that was done
correctly and as it has survived is how
bags are delivered into passengers you
either want to get through that space
because you don't have bags to claim or
you have to stop and pick up your bag
and right outside in close proximity to
the baggage claim is the curb and the
curb is accessible through a large
floor-to-ceiling window that actually
goes from the ground floor of the
building to the roof right here the two
models that are frequently used are the
flat plate and the inclined baggage
carousel in which bags are either
delivered to the center of the belt
either from above or below so either
from a tunnel or from right away in the
ceiling unfortunately this device has
been retrofitted into a lot of buildings
where the columns are right there or
right here so the moment you have that
column there about that much of the belt
is not usable because you can't stand
there and you know grab your bag or
chase your bag so using that in the new
terminal we've allowed for nine of these
devices to be installed in a smaller
area they provide more of the quote
presentation area so you can actually
put more people around them so it's a
very very efficient way in practical way
for delivering the the baggage the key
to it is to space them far enough apart
which is generally a rule of thumb is
about 60 feet from the center of one to
the center of the other because that's
60 feet allows for people to queue and
form another island around it with carts
and people waiting and you know bags out
here and again it's this ease of
movement in existing terminals like
LaGuardia you get the frustration comes
out of a combination of short waiting
for baggage but then the overcrowding
situation that once you have your bags
it kind of doesn't enable you to freely
move through the space
there's lots of causes for frustration
at airports everything from delays
incurred because of Airlines requests of
weather but the last thing that we'd
want to have is the building is the
terminal contribute to that frustration
if there's something that's taught us
about these buildings in the last 50 or
60 years is they you have to adapt to
change space is a great contributor to
success in architecture and that
contributes to a kind of a less
stressful more entertaining and more
memorable experience